تفجير سد نوفا كخوفك جنوبي اوكرانيا فتح
نيران الاتهامات المتبادله بين الروس
والاوكران السد يقع في خرسون التي تعد
الجغرافيا مدينه اوكرانيه لكنها تخضع
لسيطره روسيه الطرفان يتبادلان الاتهامات
حول من فجر السد اما الصحف الغربيه فتحدثت
عن الفرضيات الاكثر ترجيحا صحيفه فاينشل
تايمز سردت الفرضيه الروسيه التي تقول انه
عمل تخريبي متعمد من قبل الاوكران عن طريق
قصف جوي بهدف حرمان شبه جزيره القرم من
المياه لكن الاوكران يتحدثون عن انفجار
داخل غرفه المحرك الرئيسيه لسد نوفا عن
طريق الغام وضعها الروس في البنيه
الداخليه للسد ما ولد انفجارا داخليا ضخما
الاوكران يدفعون بنظريه ان قصف سد نوفاك
خوفكا من الخارج لن يؤثر على هيكله
الخارجي بالطريقه التي حدثت خاصه وان
السده ترابي تم بناؤه من خلال ضغط طبقات
متتاليه من التربه باستخدام مواد مقاومه
للاختراق محاطا بحجاره صلبه وخرسان مسلحه
امر يقول خبراء لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز انه
لو تم داخليا فسيتطلب مئات الارطال من
المتفجرات لاحداث خرق في هيكل السد لكن في
المقابل فان احداث نفس الاثر عبر القصف
الخارجي يتطلب كميات مضاعفه من المتفجرات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات